you might be familiar with holograms or
three-dimensional light projections from
movies like star wars i regret that i am
unable to present my father's request to
in person
hi i'm tim draper now they're popping up
in workplaces as businesses find ways to
battle zoom fatigue in this era of
remote working tech executives say this
kind of hologram may soon be common in
conference rooms around the world hey
phil can you check out these new designs
and let me know if you're approved
i think the pandemic has accelerated
just the need and use of this technology
it's it's a little easier to create a
hologram of yourself your colleagues
along with beaming into meetings or
events
holograms are being used in fields like
healthcare engineering education gaming
and entertainment so we see this being a
stepping stone for people
to get creative about how they teach
whether it's on the modeling side
whether it's on the 3d structure side
chemical engineering it's a whole new
universe but hologram technology could
have limits in the workplace they also
tend to have a higher price point
compared to other types of communication
technology with zoom fatigue spreading
could this be the next evolution in
remote work
how practical are holograms in the
office and are they worth the cost
hi i'm david nussbaum i'm the founder
and ceo of proto proto is a los angeles
based tech company that offers
life-sized photorealistic projections
[Music]
there is 30 000 lumens of interior light
so whatever the content is whether it's
a 3d model or whether it's an nft or
whether it's a real person materializing
in before you it'll appear like that
person is there prono's holograms appear
on a seven foot tall booth or a smaller
24 inch box a user can beam in from
anywhere in the world they just need a
camera a plain backdrop as well as a set
of speakers and microphones to record
them in real time but we have also just
created an app that allows the person to
use their iphone so in time when a an
employee or a ceo or anybody needs to
beam into a location they don't need to
have an entire studio set up all they
need is a phone and our free app the
hologram market is projected to double
in growth from 2.7 billion dollars in
2020 to about 5.4 billion dollars in
2024.
this is largely driven by the
technology's wide range of commercial
applications
the hologram industry right now is made
up of both tech giants and smaller
startups so companies from the big tech
giants like google and microsoft are
involved in the space as well as smaller
startups and they each vary with what
they're offering to consumers and
businesses
right now produce hologram system is
largely aimed at business customers
clients like netflix t-mobile and
formula e-racing have used the device to
communicate between offices or beam into
trade shows entertainment events and
seminars
proto's larger device is priced at sixty
thousand dollars or it can be rented for
about twenty five thousand dollars per
event we were recently at new york
fashion week where we were able to beam
in fashion models from all over the
place into the device they have the
ability to walk around also because we
can track people we're using it for
financial institutions and inter-office
communication
for telecoms
for office work meanwhile the university
of central florida is using proto's
hologram device as an education
something tool we do all the time
medical students can interact with both
live and pre-recorded projections of
patients with a variety of medical
conditions
it's like telehealth but it's a hologram
health because the person is really
standing there before you with all of
her shadows and and reflections and
volumetric effects
other hologram firms are more focused on
the consumer market such as san
diego-based iken early next year it
plans to launch a hologram device that
users can clip into their mobile phone
the company says it will be able to
project a transparent 3d hologram of
people on video conferencing calls
it's more comfortable to look at at
something that's spatially normalized to
your environment it's also less intense
light and we retain the color saturation
we retain the resolution the detail but
we also soften that light energy to the
point where now it's one more normalized
for the environment but it's less harsh
to the eyes so you can actually
experience it for longer without getting
fatigued
estimated to cost less than 500
eiken says the device will allow users
to move media from their phone directly
into the holographic display we refer to
it as a interplay between states so you
have something on the 2d screen you can
actually swipe it up into the
environment it'll immediately be
translated and then you can swipe it
back to the phone which is quite cool
icons hologram devices are currently
being used by several businesses
including a u.s military contractor that
is using the technology to help find and
stock inventory in large warehouses
holograms are also being used to help
aid on-the-job field repair and research
microsoft's hololens 2 was used to
create a deep sea exploration vessel's
holographic laboratory wearing the
headsets allowed scientists to interact
with holographic diagrams and
collaborate from labs and offices around
the world you have companies using them
to remotely train people for jobs that
require
people to really understand how
a big machine works
still the often bulky equipment and
costs associated with holograms means
they have yet to prove useful for daily
interactions
while there are some companies out there
looking to make these devices more
consumer friendly and cheaper right now
it's still pretty out of reach for most
consumers so even if a consumer wanted
to use it with their friends or family
it's a little out of most people's price
range as with any new form of technology
hologram experiences are not always
seamless the user experience varies
greatly depending on what type of device
is being used for instance some are more
photorealistic while others are more
cartoony certain holograms can only work
in specific types of lighting while
others require access to a strong power
source
you can have holograms that perhaps
don't render as well in someone's
computer because of something they're
using or maybe their internet is just
really bad that day and they will be
able to see you the way you're meant to
be seen while hologram companies push
for more widespread adoption growing
demand is driving millions of dollars of
investments in the tech and venture
capital world you have
players like like a tech giant like
google you know starting to enter the
space as well
and i think you're starting to see
smaller startups
gain more interest more funding and just
actually be something that we don't talk
about as something in the movies and
something that you might be able to use
every day or you know see more often
during events or in the workplace
[Music]